Mary is with us Mary's in Kentucky hi
Mary how are you hi fine how are you
better than I deserve how can I help
it's really nice to talk to you and I
have been trying to implement these
practices for a really long time and I'm
my husband I are married we have a four
year old daughter and I'm trying to I
grew up kind of like love I have to be a
single mom and kind of like well she
just sorry she passed away recently I'm
sorry how long ago in December so she
scratched and clawed and worked three
jobs to raise your kids yep
a lady of great nobility yes but we like
you know we grow kind of without a lot
in them I just don't want my daughter to
grow up that way so I have this really
hard time every time I start getting on
track I'll be like well we deserve that
her she deserves that
and it really looks more like the
mentality of it and I wanted to see if
you get a dress that oh oh I like be
honored to and I'd like to spend a
minute unpacking it with you do you mind
hanging through a break with me because
I'm heading into a commercial break okay
hang with me we'll come back and talk
about it because I think you're facing
the stuff a lot of people who have faced
Mary is with us in Kentucky
raised by a single mom shortage of money
in the household growing up which there
usually is 52 percent of single moms
live below the poverty level and her mom
just passed away not long ago so it's
emotional for her to talk about so when
her kids come wanting something it's
it's hard for her to say no she feels
like they're entitled everybody's
entitled that and we just make it happen
even if we're doing it out of balance in
the budget or even worse going into debt
how do I avoid that was her question is
that a fair summary Mary yes yep okay
and he's only four but mostly it's like
her education and stuff like that you
know I just you know I want of course
you want the best for your kids
okay so do you suffer from psychological
disorders due to the lack when you were
a child um I mean my mom definitely did
I know I should tell you oh well yeah I
think I have a definitely have like I
don't know what I would call it like a
paranoia about it yes for sure
no I mean I mean are you like in
treatment with a psychiatrist a
counselor a pastor or your medication
due to the problems oh yeah yeah I mean
I do see a therapist and yes I have I
think it's all due to that yeah yeah we
grew up a pretty turbulent childhood
though was that the women there's
difference between the turbulence and
the money yes
well both and we had both so but I think
you know that lack all the time you feel
and my mom tried her best to keep us
like in good schools and stuff but then
you're the one that doesn't have
anything you know and you know that it
gets in your soul like I understand yeah
yeah I've got I got a friend that grew
up he's worth about 20 million dollars
and he grew up dirt poor which you're
from Kentucky I'm from Tennessee some
people don't know what that means that
means he grew up in Appalachia in a
house that the floor was dirt right yeah
yeah so poor white trash right and you
know and had to you know had to overcome
that he's worth 20 million now probably
somewhat as a result of that that's why
I was asking about how this head of
did you because my contention is is that
sometimes growing up that way the
horrible parts of it the shame and the
degrading parts of it are not worth
anything I'm with you on that and
certainly that's not going to be your
child's issue anyway we're not going to
be more near that stuff but sometimes
those end up being plusses okay
I know lots of people that were raised
in lower middle-class homes or even
lower income homes were but the homes
were full of character it sound like
it's not like there were other problems
in this house but but there was no money
but there was lots of character and lots
of love yeah and then they came out
actually better than some kids who get
everything they asked for which we used
to when I was a kid we called those kids
spoiled brats that's not a phrase you
hear you don't hear that phrase emore
where you say I spoiled they spoiled
their children like they ruined them
people don't say that anymore but that's
I still see those kids but they don't
call them that anymore it's probably
politically incorrect or something so
all of that to say if I'm in your shoes
just listening to you I think what's
really I think you're a really really
really good mom and I think you love
your kids so much you would do anything
for them which is the definition of a
good mom and what you have to be careful
of there is you have to define what a
good life for the kid is I'll give you
an example a kid who never experiences
sacrifice strain delayed pleasure or
work hard enough that they sweat if a
kid has never experienced any of those
they've not been raised very well right
I grew I know a lot of people like that
and I definitely don't like that's a
trust-fund I be looking for a reality
show right right and so we want your kid
to experience some lack because money is
always finite there is never enough
money to buy everything you want all
right and if you try that it's like
trying to take enough drugs to be happy
it won't work for you so you know it's
so we don't want to give her that we
don't want it to have the severe lack
where she feels threatened
unsafe or shamed or something like that
but entitled right and so what I'm
trying to say is let's redefine what
good mom is okay good mom is not
swinging the pendulum from the where you
grew up all the way over to the entitled
brat good mom is we're gonna control the
environment better because we have more
money than mom did and we've learned
from some of the other mistakes as great
as mom was we may learn from some of the
other mistakes that she did and so we're
gonna swing the pendulum not too far the
other way and the way you do that is you
go okay the definition of a good mom is
my kid needs to learn to work my kid
needs to learn to be generous my kidneys
learned that the that the substance of
life is what's in your heart not what's
in your garage or your bedroom wall the
substance of your life is not the
version of iPhone you carry it's
character and love and kindness and
compassion and honesty and work and so
the things in your heart you install
those things in her heart and you keep
her safe and fed where she doesn't feel
the lack to to an extreme like you did
then you're a great mom if you allow
this to go to the other side then you've
taken your good intentions and used them
to ruin your kid which is what that's
what you're afraid of it's why you call
me yep yep yeah I just I have a hard
time giving her that sense when I don't
feel that way though like I feel like
scared well what do we don't have money
to do this you know and so I don't want
her to pick up on me feeling like that
you know well that's true but here's the
thing that's your job as mom your mom is
to carry the big stuff right right kid
doesn't carry the big stuff they don't
carry house payments I don't carry they
don't that she's four she doesn't carry
the worries of how college is gonna be
paid for that's your job you carried
those worries and you square your
shoulders and you spend time in prayer
and you talk to God about it and say God
help me carry this and you carry it and
you can do it but you're not gonna pass
it on to her you listen you I think you
think you're more anxiety-ridden than
you are I've been listening to you for
ten minutes here on the air and there's
a lot of verbal cues when people are
freaked out you don't have any of them
or I can hide it really well yeah it may
be maybe you may be an excellent
impostor but I doubt it I'm pretty good
at this I've been doing it thirty years
so you might be I don't know but I I
really think you're doing better than
you feel like you are you carry the big
stuff
you let her experience some victories a
lot of safety and and some pain under
control
Rachel Cruise came in at 14 years old we
gave her her first checkbook the oldest
child her older sister never bounced a
check in her life she's a real keeper
Rachel bounced one the first week
actually bounced three the first week I
let her experience the pain I made her
go to the bank
her mother drove her down there and sit
down with the banker and apologized for
lying because when you write checks on
account there's not money in there
that's lying and we don't do lying if
we're Renzi's yeah that poor child was
abused by her mean old daddy you know I
she ain't bounced that dadgum check
since so something worked I want them to
feel pain under my wing where it's
controlled pain so that when they get
real pain they know how to handle it
because pain is coming conflict is
coming and you got to have those tools
and that's our job as moms and dads
you're doing a great job hold on I'm
gonna send you a copy of the smart money
smart kids book that Rachel and I wrote
together actually that story's in that
book of me making her go down there her
version of the story is even funnier
because she's full full of freakin drama
but um she was always that kid but uh
yeah I get that read that book and you
know that'll help you with the money
parts of teaching your kid about money
smart money smart kids is for parents to
teach their kids how to handle money but
built under the how to handle it is the
this whole thing of what do we derive
from having money around safety security
the acquisition of things that are fun
you can't buy happiness but you can buy
fun fun can be purchased it's always
temporary though and
there's always a newer one and a bigger
one and a better one and there's no end
of that thread that you pull on the
sweater
it's called materialism if you keep
pulling that thread it's called
conspicuous consumption and you're
looking for love and all the wrong
places is Mickey Gilley used to singer
was that lead I was leaving that the
urban cowboy music looking for love in
all the wrong places
that's what you don't want that I'm
doing that's what the culture does and
then they end up deeply in debt find
stuff they can't afford with money they
don't have to impress people they don't
really like this is the Dave Ramsey show